ich kann so zwei millionen views pro tag
besorgen hier das ist marten er betreibt
die webseite von reviews über dr youtube
views verkauft während seiner
abrufzahlen künstlich in die höhe
treiben will der greift auf die dienste
von leuten wie martin zurück ich
verbinde damit 15.000 dollar je nach
monat manche monate lohnen sich mehr
manche weniger
in diesem video schauen wir uns genau an
wie das geschäft mit fate wie es
funktioniert also was nutzt ob das
überhaupt legal ist und was youtube
dagegen tun
[Musik]
im schatten der großen digitalen
plattformen wie facebook youtube und
instagram hat sich eine ganze industrie
entwickelt zahllose seite verkaufen
nicht nur youtube views dennoch likes
follower oder place bei spotify wir
haben testweise videos gekauft auch bei
martin 500 abrufe kosten je nach website
zwischen fünf und zehn dollar
und es funktioniert diese ist wenig
spannende video haben wir auf einem
kanal mit gerade mal 19 abonnenten
gepostet die gekauften 500 abrufe waren
innerhalb weniger stunden da generiert
werden die videos ab gar nicht von
martin selbst er ist nur zwischenhändler
ich kenne ein paar websites da sind
meine große held ließ ich nehme an dass
die die jus wiederum von anderen
bekommen
es ist wie ein spinnennetz die abrufe
genau generiert werden das war selbst
machen nicht aber wer kauft sich
überhaupt deuce martin hat mir erzählt
dass er kunden aus der ganzen welt hat
auch aus deutschland und viele seiner
kunden sind musiker kürzlich hatte ein
künstler der 3,4 millionen abonnenten
hat wie es gekauft sondern mehrere
millionen in deutschland haben wohl auch
viele influenza schon mal hughes gekauft
sagt er hier christoph peschek ist
online marketing fachmann und hat eine
analysesoftware für youtube entwickelt
ich glaube probiert hat es fast jeder
youtube kanal der auf youtube etwas
werden will
es ist halt wirklich nur so ein kleines
einmaliges blitzen und danach merkt man
so richtig passiert da nichts
die houston zwar da aber es kommen keine
abonnenten zustande es kommt keine
interaktion zustande
und dann wird das auch wieder aufgehört
und dann gibt es einfach eine sehr
kleine gruppe von leuten die wirklich
sagen ich gehe ein dass ich betrüge
es sind ja die kleinen und mittleren
influenza die man da vielleicht
vermuten könnte kann man jetzt natürlich
sagen mein gott wie es kaufen tut keinem
weh aber wer views kauft könnte sich
juristischen ärger einhandeln sagt er
hier michael terhaag fachanwalt für ein
tier
ich mache letztendlich für mich eine
unlautere werbung weil ich natürlich so
tue als wir nicht vielmehr views
tatsächlich gehabt habe als es der fall
war das ist so was ähnliches wie
gekaufte bewertung die sind auch
unzulässig das heißt konkret vor gegen
dagegen kann eigentlich nur der
portalbetreiber weil der kann
nachvollziehen wenn hier innerhalb von
wenigen stunden aus einem land aus einem
ort vielleicht sogar vom selben rechner
ganz viele hughes stattfinden dass man
wirklich verklagt wird ist also nicht so
super wahrscheinlich aber es gibt ein
anderes größeres risiko youtube selbst
die können jemanden natürlich einfach
knallhart sperren das ist ein verstoß
gegen die allgemeinen
geschäftsbedingungen
und die lassen sich da auch nicht auf
der nase herumtanzen
und wenn ich dann gut gehendes kann gut
gehenden kanal gut gehen das profil habe
und wird dann einfach rausgeschmissen
dann trifft mich das vielleicht noch
viel härter als die post vom gericht
wir hätten gern mit youtube darüber
gesprochen wie die mit fake news umgehen
aber alles was wir bekommen haben waren
ziemlich allgemeines schriftliches
statement durch den einsatz von eigenen
technologien arbeitet youtube ständig
daran zu verhindern dass die anzahl der
aufrufe eines videos durch spam bots
malware und andere mittel künstlich
erhöht wird sobald wir betrügerische
zugriffe entdecken werden sie entfernt
[Musik]
tatsächlich gab es in den vergangenen
jahren immer wieder fälle in den
abrufzahlen nachträglich korrigiert
wurden
und youtube nimmt immer mal wieder
technische änderungen vor um leuten wie
marten das leben schwer zu machen
es dauert ein bis zwei wochen nach einem
update dann haben sie herausgefunden was
verändert wurde
und das geschäft läuft wieder es ist ein
katz und maus so wie es aussieht wird
dieses katz-und-maus-spiel erstmal
weitergehen bevor ihr jetzt aber hingeht
und massenhaft fake news kauft das
allein macht niemanden zum influenza
oder wie es martin ausdrückt wenn du ein
schlechtes video hast die dafür 5.000
news corp ist das bringt nichts du
brauchst ein gutes video und eine
kombination verschiedener dinge damit
ein video erfolgreich ist wenn euch das
video gefallen hat last gern ein like da
oder wenn ihr noch fragen zum geschäft
mit fake news habt einfach kommentar
unten rein